might be getting an
aircut for suicide squad
this user m mcconnell said complete the
gift and release the aircup please
please please an atnt said
one thing at a time honestly to respond
to that in
that way means they're at least trying
to get there
or considering it right yeah i guess not
how's it going reject nation greg and
john here we got some snyder verse
information to discuss
some important stuff but before that
it's gonna make this super quick a lot
of people i'm sure already like where's
the rest of your zack snyder's justice
league movie reactions where's the rest
of the parts the being worked on okay
there's been a lot of blocking issues
and then even the
ones that were able to go up i mean
those aren't monetized well they are
they're shared revenue
so you know our thousand viewers in
korea
are really enjoying helping pay the
bills on those reactions
that's fine i just wanted to get them to
you and we're just trying to get them to
you as long as they can be
public and not blocked they'll get to
you okay we just want them to be the
best looking quality they can be
care about quality of the reaction more
than anything else there were parts of
the reactions from yesterday that i
almost
just eliminated entirely but i was like
no there's got to be a way to figure out
how to keep it in here
with some of the audio because this
needs to be part of the reaction even if
it's not monetized
we just wanted to be the best quality
and they will get to you this they
should be all be out this week
eventually now that's out of the way we
got to talk about some [ __ ]
from um boris karloff from warner media
aka and sarnoff i remember the name like
that karloff sarnoff anywho
there's a lot of people who are breaking
this article down already there's a
bunch of movie channels where she was on
variety
and the biggest takeaways i'm sure
you've already heard
by this point we'll link the article in
the description box if you want to read
it in detail
i don't want to focus specifically on
breaking down word-for-word
what she's talking about here have been
the main takeaways just to get them out
of the way
one is they have no interest in
continuing the snyder verse that's
essentially what's being said
um they flat out shut down
they're going to do the a or cut flat
out just no that
out of anything that was crystal clear
that was the most clear one
that they have they're not going to be
doing it third
the biggest debate that i'm seeing
happened especially for those
that weren't for the snyder cut that
really have an issue with the fan base
of the snyder cut
they really focused heavily on the part
in the article
that was about the toxic side of fandom
and there's a lot of people i've seen
all over social media the ones who
aren't for it are like this is exactly
why this is a hundred percent why
you guys are not getting the
continuation of your snyder verse
because of toxic
fans which is the dumbest argument in
the world
every fandom i'm not saying it's okay
we've been on youtube for years you know
how many people have told me to kill
myself
yeah i mean like death threats i get
like i
i know what it's like and this is from
every fandom i've gotten it from but
right
every side of fandom is rough don't try
to use this as your argument
maybe it plays a factor i can't say 100
it doesn't does or doesn't but
as long as they're making their money
you know whatever it was just an odd
timing for it to come out it did
feel like snyder cut is having all this
great success this
massive success and then like the
few days later they're like you just
gotta bury the hatchet
no don't get any more excited i gotta
put this all down no no no
it was kind of sudden this conversation
a few weeks
later might have made more sense but the
week and after
i just want to throw my hat in the ring
in the most clear-cut way
and say that uh i think you'd be
absolutely
foolish to not continue the snyder verse
in any way anyway like maybe you won't
get your justice league too maybe you
won't get your justice league three but
there are definitely stories to tap into
that can continue on its own way
with zack snyder maybe shepherding or
guiding or producing you know something
along those lines
here's the difference between the zack
snyder films
and the other movies in the dceu which i
like majority of them and i'm not gonna
act like i don't i like majority of them
and a couple of them i really love the
difference is is
there's you need a passionate fan base
that's the whole thing that drives
like yes aquaman might have made a
billion dollars it did
but i don't feel the fan base for
aquaman
is anywhere near as passionate as what's
been
from man of steel to zack snyder's
justice league i mean think about it
zack snyder's justice league that fan
base
was so strong and so passionate for such
a long time
that that's what drove it to get to this
point and
here's another reason why i think it's
like even before zach saunders justice
league he might have been able to argue
with it a bit more
but the fact of the matter is this the
movie came out
it's zack snyder's highest rated movie
from critics and audiences and
yes it not only satisfied the passionate
fans
i'm seeing plenty of people plenty of
people who don't like man of steel and
bbs
but really enjoyed this movie
a lot of people so not only did it
satisfy that passionate fan base
it garnered some the garnered fans as
well i can't say everyone i know there's
gonna be people in there like no screw
this movie no i hate it
but there's plenty of people who didn't
like any of this before and are like
i've actually cosmonaut variety hour is
a channel i love
i love i love his videos i really do and
i disagree with him on so many things
but i find him so entertaining and so
funny
even in the fact that i disagree with
him so much and he even enjoyed the
movie
red letter media one of my favorite
channels i thought they'd tear this
movie a new one beginning to end
and while they you know make fun of it
and while they like clown on stuff you
know they have some criticisms that
sure are are valid i was actually
surprised by the fact that i'm like they
actually seem like they enjoyed this
you know dan murrell doesn't like man of
steel and vvs
ended up really enjoying the hell out of
this spoiler review is all mainly
dedicated to why he loves this movie
this movie won over people
so this is the time where you ride the
momentum
of the snyder verse i get wb's have
plans but i'm like
why do you guys want to stick to your
guns now on your plans how many times
have you guys scrapped your plans with
dc films
you scrapped them so many freaking times
why like
rework them because clearly this is
where the momentum
is this is where the passion is this
movie was tr like top
trending on social media for so many
days in a row
yeah i just think it would be absolutely
silly to not
lean into where the passionate
excitement is
and instead go put that away we want to
do our own thing
you know yeah i agree with you
i mean like she goes on in this article
to say like you know we have so much we
want to do across so much
media and i feel like that alone is sort
of argument for
why not include zack snyder or even
david ayer in a different way i mean
that's the shortest answer in the whole
interview is
nope we're not going to pursue the air
cut but yeah with certain stories
even now in the current umbrella of dc
you've got joker which is not attached
to any one continuity so i feel like
that alone leaves you open to yeah
pursuing something with zack snyder who
clearly like yeah
they the fans were there to the point
that they you know a big studio
completely turned their ship
on something and walked something back
and that doesn't happen
out of nowhere and so i get how they
might not want to
carry that around moving forward but at
the same time
it seems like he's certainly zack snyder
bringing them some good will right now
and some
attention and some subscriptions and
whatnot so yeah i get it if they want to
have one unified universe going forward
or something but at the same time
this thing is still very much alive and
so for them to go to all this effort
and then yeah opening weekend be like no
more is a little peculiar
i think something that strikes me as
otto why i wanted to play that bit
at the beginning with the a recut is
because for whoever the social media is
and maybe it's just a completely
different person who was managing it at
the time
for them to say one thing at a time
generated a lot of
excitement for the possibilities of
what's to come
clearly zack snyder's justice league was
the first thing that generated
actual excitement for hbo max so i think
some [ __ ] went down people at t and
warner brothers with like walter hamada
and all that you know like
i i don't know what happened this is all
speculation
it just when you look at the narrative
and things that have been presented
it's a little bit odd to be like a year
ago this was like the thing to embrace
yeah a year ago this was the coolest
thing in the world
even the talk of the erika with having
that tease back then was like oh my god
they might do it and then it just
completely a few days after the movie's
released
to start shutting [ __ ] down just like no
no
it's done leave us alone we're not doing
restore the snyder verse no air cut no
no like that's how this article reads
essentially is no no no no no
and i just think that would be a
terrible idea you want to follow the
momentum and i think
like from a business standpoint from a
business standpoint doesn't make any
sense to me like follow the momentum
follow the passion that's how you keep
people
like tuning in just let it be some
multiverse thing well and that's how so
how yeah you pull in the people who are
faithful to that into your other newer
stuff that's not that is by embracing
their taste as well and their voice as
well because it's clearly very loud you
know
and even if you have to push a haircut
back beyond your suicide squad stuff
this year i get that but yeah it just
seems like
you're actively shutting off a side of
your fan base yeah they are
i mean look is there a toxic side to the
snide record fan base
yes there is it's like different and
some people might say it's the worst
some people might say star wars is the
worst
at the end of the day i don't think it's
everyone i don't think it's the majority
like it's ridiculous to me for some
people to be thinking that it's all
because of this toxic side of fandom
like come
on kathleen kennedy would have quit that
star wars [ __ ] ages ago
now like there's also a whole lot of
celebration they say they want to be
about celebration in this article and
i'm like there's a whole lot of that too
with this and especially as the movie
has come out there's been a whole lot of
joy and a whole lot of people coming
around who hated it before who are
pleasantly surprised
yeah so guys i'd say keep
faith they might change their mind i
think it's a terrible idea to can it
terrible idea all right well subscribe
click that notification bell what do you
think about what's presented in this
article
hit that like button and last but not
least
justin has recently joined our patreon
page brand new patron here
thanks for being here my man it's good
to meet you here's what i wanted to say
to you justin
your name means classic just
fair or righteous yes
with a name like that now's your chance
to pull off all the biggest con artist
things you can do
now's the biggest chance to test how
many lies
and cheats and scams you can get away
with
because no one would suspect you with a
name like justin yeah
i've let so many justins dick me over in
my life
just because her name means just fair or
righteous so how could they be trying to
swindle you
when it's in their name exactly the new
justin bieber album is literally called
justice
justin bieber is also the most just fair
righteous very righteous guy i mean he's
a role model
so you oh wait it says
are you from carolina i guess so i take
it all back
it doesn't matter which carolina you're
from that you can't trust those
folks nope they're all awful people
bailey made one i haven't said i haven't
ever said hi to you yet
i just saw your pledge and i'm going out
of town tonight to shout you out
thanks for being here do you appreciate
your support talking to you
hopefully sometime in the next few weeks
thank you dude